but it's like when you think about it
that whole industry it's like an
industry that's subsidized meaning like
the majority of it operates at a loss
like we don't have the demand for it and
it really just makes us in Dem man yeah
like that's and that's not even taking
nothing from like Serena Williams cuzz
she's like the most dominant like
basically person in like T in women's
tennis but even she admits she will get
destroyed by a a top 300 guy and she has
the guy was hung over the guy was hung
over so he was he was hung over people
were not shocked that he lost people are
shocked that he he scored a point on her
like that she scored a point on him so
it was that's the kind of stuff we're
talking about but like I don't give no
Shak or Serena she actually was like she
admitted it and stuff she's like oh yeah
I just